voilà pour ces images en direct de
Moscou on voit Vladimir Poutine toujours
accompagnée de ces quatre gouverneurs il
est 15h si vous suivez toujours sur
France 24 si vous nous rejoignez on va
continuer à décrypter ensemble ce moment
qui marque définitivement un tournant
dans cette guerre en Ukraine avec le
rattachement de ces régions à la
Fédération russe toujours avec nous
notre invité Jean de guignatie ancien
ambassadeur de France à Moscou entre
2009 et 2016 on voit ce moment très
solennelle il marque définitivement un
tournant vous êtes d'accord avec ça dans
cette guerre
écoutez il y a beaucoup d'aspects dans
ce discours il y a d'abord la
célébration de l'unité
retrouver en quelque sorte avec
l'annexion de ces territoires il y a
l'idée que la Russie incarne un combat
beaucoup plus général contre en fait les
États-Unis c'est une vraie dietrie entre
les États-Unis avec un appel au pays du
Sud il y a même un appel sous-jacent
l'Europe on sait qu'il y a chez vous des
gens qui partagent nos valeurs
multipolaires et civilisations
il y a aussi un appel à la négociation
il n'a pas trop insisté là-dessus
d'ailleurs parce que il sait très bien
que c'est irréaliste donc il y a la
référence à un monde de multipolaire
dans la Russie serait le promoteur et
donc en fait c'est un appel à tous les
pays sauf les États-Unis en fait donc
les États-Unis qui n'a pas hésité à
charger dans ce discours des revenus sur
sur un point de l'histoire en disant il
est le seul pays ce sont les seuls dans
l'histoire avoir utilisé par deux fois
l'arme nucléaire le danger il n'est pas
russe mais il est américain c'était
aussi l'occasion de tacler une nouvelle
fois les États-Unis
est passé à la fois
l'extraterritorialité du droit américain
l'imposition de valeur américaine qui ne
sont pas partagées par le reste du monde
ou qui ne serait pas partagé par le
reste du monde il y a la référence au
Christ il y a le
néocolonialisme enfin tout y passe donc
c'est vraiment d'abord une diatrigue
anti-américaine et un appel au pays du
Sud la Russie incarnant le combat contre
cette unilatéralisme américain dénoncée
par Poutine il est revenu sur un point
sur le fait que les Occidentaux aient
expulsé ces derniers mois des Russes
chef d'orchestre artistes sportifs qui
n'ont pas pris position dans cette
guerre est-ce rendez-vous en tant que
que diplomate vous estimez qu'en
agissant ainsi les Occidentaux ont
peut-être donné un argument de plus à
Vladimir Poutine qui dit regardez ne pas
être d'accord avec eux ça vaut une
expulsion est-ce que c'était une erreur
des Occidentaux de repousser tous ceux
qui n'ont pas officiellement pris
position je ne sais pas si c'est une
erreur ça dépend du degré de
conflictualité mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que c'est un argument utilisé par
Poutine pour dire vous voyez ils veulent
nous détruire ils veulent détruire la
culture russe donc en fait ça lui sert
ça lui sert totalement Bruno Darou à mes
côtés toujours on a également entendu
Vladimir Poutine accusé directement les
oxydants d'être responsable des
explosions qui elles sont à l'origine
des fuites de nortriments en mer
Baltique c'était donc un discours pour
revenir sur l'histoire sur ces annexions
mais aussi pour régler des comptes sur
l'actualité très chaude de ces derniers
jours il y a une chose qu'on n'a pas dit
quand même qui était importante je
trouve dans ce discours aussi c'est
qu'il a commencé par justifier ce qu'il
était en train de faire l'annexion de
ces territoires en recourant lui qui est
tout le temps régulièrement accusé de
violer la Charte des Nations Unies il a
il a cité un des articles de cette
charte sur le droit à
l'autodétermination des peuples et de et
de de ça à découler toute sa
démonstration pour dire ce qui bien sûr
est hautement contestable mais pour dire
voyez c'est pas nous en fait qui
annexons ce sont ses peuples qui ont
choisi on leur proposer un référendum ce
sont ces peuples qui ont choisi
librement de rejoindre la Russie
conformément à cette notion de l'ONU et
c'est donc ce droit à
l'autodétermination qui s'applique donc
en gros nous ne faisons nous ne faisons
rien de mal sur ce point justement on va
faire rebondir notre invité Jean de
greenastie justement il est revenu sur
l'histoire également de ces quatre
régions à Bruno nous disait ils avaient
leurs droits selon lui à
l'autodétermination il est aussi revenu
sur le statut particulier qu'ils avaient
lorsqu'ils étaient encore sous le jour
sous la la loi
ukrainienne en revenant sur une histoire
difficile pour eux l'impossibilité
éviter de mettre en avant leur culture
russe c'est un argument qui qu'il
fallait s'attendre à entendre dans la
bouche de Vladimir Poutine
oui tout à fait certains experts
s'interrogent puisque comme vous le
savez
en 2021
l'Ukraine a interdit l'enseignement du
russe dans les écoles enfin les
l'enseignement
ukrainien est devenu obligatoire donc
cet argument de la culture de la langue
russe et la cité un poème il a parlé de
la langue c'est un argument très fort
pour pour Poutine vis-à-vis de sa propre
opinion à laquelle il s'adresse
principalement quand même pour justifier
son opération militaire spéciale entre
guillemets un mot peut-être sur le le
droit l'auto-détermination des peuples
tout le monde sait qu'il y a une espèce
de contradiction en permanence entre
l'intégrité territoriale des États et
l'auto-détermination des peuples qui
sont dedans et en fait Poutine l'utilise
à son profit et là il met l'accent plus
sur le taux de termination des peuples
on sait très bien par exemple qu'un pays
comme la Chine mais plus l'accent sur
l'intégrité territorial en fait on voit
que ces deux principes sont utilisés
alternativement en fonction des intérêts
des uns et des autres
il a utilisé là aujourd'hui cet argument
sur l'auto détermination des peuples et
maintenant il va utiliser l'argument sur
l'intégrité territoriale pour dire si
vous nous attaquez désormais vous
attaquez le territoire russe justement
parce qu'il y a encore pour préciser à
nos téléspectateurs les combats se
poursuivent toujours dans certaines
zones de ces quatre régions notamment
apoedia on l'a vu il y a encore quelques
heures il attaque les
Occidentaux leur idéologie aussi le
modèle traditionnel de la famille c'est
aussi l'occasion pour Vladimir Poutine
pour dire nous ne sommes pas comme eux
avec la question du genre qui fait son
chemin il faut le dire en
Occident mais qui selon lui n'a pas sa
place en Russie oui bah là
selon nos critères à nous il serait
classé sur l'échelle politique à la
droite de la droite voire à l'extrême
droite en tout cas dans un camp
ultra conservateur qui existe
y compris dans nos démocraties ou à des
voilà des gens ils ont tout à fait le
droit de penser ça parce que voilà
l'ordre naturel en quelque sorte c'est
un homme une femme pour la famille donc
évidemment c'est une exclusion un rejet
très profond et parfois très hostile de
tout ce qui est effectivement les
questionnements sur le genre de tout là
il n'a pas cité le lobby LGBT mais en
général ça fait partie de la de la
panoplie tout ça c'est pour ce courant
de pensée une forme de décadence de
l'Occident et il l'utilise pour dire non
seulement il faut sortir d'un système de
domination coloniale qui dure en fait
depuis cinq ou six siècles parce qu'il
est remonté assez loin il a fait
effectivement une de son histoire un peu
décousue par moment mais enfin il l'a
cité mais aussi c'est la volonté
d'imposer un modèle qui ne correspond
pas à nos valeurs et comme ça a été très
justement dit par votre invité aussi qui
ne correspond pas aux valeurs de
beaucoup d'autres pays y compris dans
l'hémisphère sud et de ce point de vue
force de constater que tout ce qu'il a
dit notamment sur le modèle sociétal des
démocraties occidentales aujourd'hui mes
combattu par la Russie mais pas
uniquement par beaucoup de pays dans le
monde vous êtes d'accord avec ça
excusez-moi est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça Jean delignation est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord qu'au-delà de
cette question territoriale au-delà de
cette question militaire Vladimir
Poutine voulait également montrer qu'il
y a une question d'idéologie qui sépare
totalement les Occidentaux des Russes
bien sûr il cherche à montrer que dans
ce combat la Russie incarne en fait les
valeurs piétinées par l'Occident au
profit en fait de des autres pays du Sud
et ça fait partie de cette espèce de
plaidoyer pour un monde multipolaire où
chacun garde ses valeurs contre les
valeurs occidentales pour l'essentiel et
justifier en quelque sorte le combat de
la Russie comme la pointe du combat pas
du Sud contre ce qu'il appelle
l'Occident collectif et donc il justifie
en quelque sorte cette guerre et cette
annexion
puis également parler de l'actualité
très chaude en disant un peu tout à
l'heure Bruno il a accusé les
Occidentaux d'être responsable des
exposants à l'origine des fuites de
North stream en mer Baltique puisqu'il y
a quelques heures le Kremlin c'est du
favorable à une enquête internationale
oui tout à fait il a alors je crois même
attendez il faut que je retrouve mes
notes mais je crois même que concernant
cet épisode bien précis il a pas employé
le thermoxydanto il employait le terme
anglo-saxon
c'est donc une attaque ciblée donc
ce soit les Américains soit les
Britanniques bon on sent que là encore
ça vise plutôt les Américains qui sont
pris effectivement à une infrastructure
internationale qui au passage à partir
en partie à la Russie Nord Stream North
stream 2
et ça lui a donné ensuite l'occasion de
dénoncer le diktat de la violence qui
est celui des États-Unis un voyait dans
dans la foulée donc effectivement
il rejette toute responsabilité dans ces
sabotages ou ses attentats comment
voudra mais qui ont touché le les deux
gazoduc Nord Stream 1 et 9 stream